[Music]
[Music]
Sunday night [ __ ] fill up those
bolts you got a big week coming why [ __ ]
around you know Sam
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here back in southern Los
Angeles I had a tremendous time in
Philadelphia I love you [ __ ]
savages no gluten-free don't know that
[ __ ] they're straight-up gangster of
debt it's the Lord's Day cut something
what he got me yellow for I got some
tremendous weeds I got some [ __ ] Paris
oh gee Larry oh gee I got a little Paris
so cheap they are little containers
the death powder you saying just report
lime people want to know I'm here to
[ __ ] tell you uncle Joey's alive and
kickin look at the eyeballs right here
that's right [ __ ] it's a
beautiful day
it's almost all my gonna nap had a
shrimp cocktail who's better than meals
[Music]
little [ __ ] clouds of debt I'm gonna
fill up with this [ __ ] thing here I
thought all right by Google appetizers
and let's just go [ __ ] [ __ ]
straight bro
I missed you [ __ ] and did that
one live from Philadelphia the [ __ ]
people will be panicked I don't need
that aggravation I'm trying to smoke
everything get my head together people
beeping and they're like I'm stuck on a
[ __ ] red light I'm just trying to get
my head together that's it like a dog
will [ __ ] Americans allow for walk
around with some [ __ ] dog you better
get the [ __ ] anyway
[Music]
deep into the murky waters the
underworld we uncle Joey and I'm saying
you gotta get ready for the week it's a
big [ __ ] week your goals are written
your shoes are shined your underwears
are Fulton and you're ready to attack
[ __ ] a thing called life anyway I'm a
little jazzed up I'm home for five weeks
I have no surgery at jujitsu I got the
special coming
you know me vote I'm a man of many
[ __ ] avenues but we're here we got to
sit down we got to [ __ ] grab your
nuts looking till your business say you
know what
suck my dick [ __ ] I'm coming in
with my eyes closed I don't give a [ __ ]
jack
cuz I'm taking a chance Columbus did why
not I took a chance [ __ ] 30 years ago
i should have been going 2000 life
no-parole But Here I am [ __ ] making it
happen with my little [ __ ] periscope
family smoking dope and cracking stupid
[ __ ] jokes we all laugh and giggle but
hey we're here and we're putting it
together that's the most important thing
in the [ __ ] world then you're putting
it together maybe it's not together
right now and you're down and you're
depressed but there's a [ __ ] if actually
it will if you chip away you chip away
chip away BAM there's your [ __ ]
masterpiece me I'm still chipping away
I'm saying you got a chip chip chip away
to the [ __ ] I couldn't imagine life
I'm not [ __ ] fighting everything you
gotta fight for your right you know Sam
not the party but to get your dick
sucked you got it you gotta fight for
your right to be you that's it [ __ ] all
the party were party the party anthem
was still 54 closed
guinness Tammy you see that back the
police his breathing has made me mop
bigger [ __ ] clowns than ever I only
want a little drape the Pens like these
[ __ ] dudes would take [ __ ] bad
sign
look at me Blanc pounds of waste [ __ ]
paper if you're gonna blow a cloud it
but I have a [ __ ] THC to the gills
and that [ __ ] anyway one down
what the Gulf best rap is [ __ ] Paris
oh Jesus e with the [ __ ] all the fuss is
about
and then it's I went to Paris listen I
went the perennial soon as I got off the
plane about 11:25 I swung by perennial
when I got ready for the [ __ ] next
few days I didn't bring the wheat up as
I brought my luggage up I left the wheat
in the car had a brown bag dry and
understanding it was 90 degrees today
all this weed is my finger-banging this
[ __ ] right now it's nicely dry
my cell I like my roof I don't like my
reefa wet replaced every four went out
of the animal my we went like a nice
umbrella that's like it before
THC [ __ ] but the wall from BAM
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about that's why
I'm talking about some people looking at
me who enjoy you just get nine man that
man that man go get the week in
perspective
I'm breaking down my days I'm breaking
down my [ __ ] map of daddy understand
me tell me how away and little Timmy
came out last night they drove from
[ __ ] Secaucus straight to
philadelphia back that's what I'm
talking about soldiers of debt anyway I
spent smoking this boat ain't a lot of
people I'm [ __ ] stoned okay I just
carried it off a little better sometimes
I'm storm my eyes just gave up my eyes
tapped out 19 [ __ ] they eat their
weight listen we will we're sick of
trying to get read and going back but we
can't keep doing this [ __ ] no more we
just want to stay [ __ ] read all the
time
[Music]
look at that man
you did the [ __ ] fire the part was
coming on video that's how we're doing
it baby
I already took my my six drops of CBD
oil to get tuned up the winner the
[ __ ] jet lag and I'm ready for the
week
I took the map I might meet dinner
tonight you know in the dorm and have a
nice little [ __ ] smoothie to put the
fruit back at my body to get back for
the week and that's it without digit to
this week there to podcast one day and
maybe Thursday actually to break you can
leave for the 4th of July weekend and
get entertained you can crack some
[ __ ] jokes and we see what sticks and
you're part of a [ __ ] special you
know you won't go Joey absolutely sure
you come over Joey like that joke
purple cat myself whatever
but joy was at the chitter-chatter I'm
stoned to the gills that will happen
when you smoke this [ __ ] net you get
all [ __ ] euphoric and he's got
chitchat gonna hit you and you hear the
ambulances it's all over anyway you know
I love your [ __ ] all right I'm
gonna go put on three [ __ ] superb
savage songs for you now give equal of
motivation for the week cuz you know I
love you [ __ ] cuz without you
there ain't no flavor your final
insanity
well you [ __ ] there's no me I'm
just a [ __ ] regulation bum but I got
you as an army it's all for them and
Iulia strength the strength
how would you go with me they want to be
with us [ __ ] they gotta work their
way and like we did smoke em reefers
that and [ __ ] my neck beside
that I love you guys it's gonna be a
beautiful [ __ ] week man I don't know
what your life is cooked it but and all
the beauty starts in your [ __ ] head
if you go into the week that guy's gonna
be a bad week it's gonna be a bad
[ __ ] week but if you're going all the
beauty starts in the [ __ ] Kokan and
everything else falls into place Eric
and I'm just a [ __ ] dummy and I know
that do you imagine you people who went
to college educate you got a family who
loves you
how you go I love you [ __ ]
see you tomorrow Churchill spoke to the
girls